governing socialist party deputies
took the stand to denounce president
elior mehta
they say he abandoned his obligation to
remain politically neutral
and supported the opposition in the
country's general election
in april bro
bro they moved to have him impeached and
won
handily 104 deputies in the 140 seat
chamber voted in favor
thirty of them from the opposition the
constitutional court must now decide
meta's fate
in what is an unprecedented political
situation even for albania's highly
personal politics
only seven deputies voted against
impeachment
one of them getan getani says that's
because many opposition mps are loyal to
prime minister eddie rama
the presidency is the only institution
prime minister rama doesn't control
he wants to get meta out of the way
before september
because he's afraid meta won't swear in
the new parliament and cabinet
mata has a lot of evidence that the
elections were not properly carried out
[Music]
mehta has said nothing in public and
dismissed the impeachment as a joke
in private he spent the day hosting folk
dances at the presidential office
but he and rama have clashed over
elections before
prime minister rama's suspicions go back
to 2019
when president mehta suggested changing
the date of local elections that were
due to be held across the country
so that the opposition democratic party
could also participate
after initially boycotting the process
rama accused meta of siding with the
democrats
held a session of parliament to censure
him and vow to get rid of him
rama says the impeachment is principled
and has nothing to do with personal
disagreements you know
it's not at all a problem between
me and him it's a big problem between
him
and the country and the role and
the duty and you know the
very very important uh
guarantee that the president is in a
in a parliamentary republic
founded the opposition party movement
for socialist integration
or lsi which his wife now leads so many
believe he is not
out of the political game if the
constitutional court removes meta
parliament must elect a new president if
it doesn't
the country will have to live with the
chief executive and a head of state
who are at war john saropolos al jazeera
tirana